There's a proposal around,
it's got a lot of interest to called the
universal basic income where everybody
is guaranteed at least a certain level
of income in the society.
Some free market economists.
So like Milton Friedman talked about a
negative income tax,
which in effect has the same features of
guaranteeing a certain level of income
for everybody as a base.
I think from a human rights and decency
standard,
there's a lot of sense to the idea that
everybody in the society should be able
to meet their basic needs.
There's,
on the other hand a sense if you give
someone a check,
uh,
whether they're trying not trying,
working,
not working.
If there's no effort,
no conditionality involved at all,
maybe we're going to get a lot of people
that are absolutely doing nothing on the
backs of those who are really working.
So the incentive issues are real.
Even if the sensitivity and decency
issues are also real.
I think that one way to handle this as a
little bit more rounded,
rather than seeing a universal basic
income as a check and a kind of an
unconditional,
a check that's just handed out as
income.
I like the idea of social democracy as
it's applied in real countries in
Europe,
in the Netherlands and Denmark,
Norway,
Sweden,
Germany,
the ideas,
everybody has access to publicly
financed healthcare.
Everybody has access to quality publicly
financed education including college
tuition.
It's not a trillion dollars of crushing
student debt,
but tuition's paid for.
Everybody has access to not only
guaranteed vacation,
but paid vacation.
Everybody has access to quality
childcare so that moms can go to work
knowing that their kids are in a healthy
nurturing environment.
Everybody has access to maternity
leaves,
so the moms and also paternity leave.
Dads can stay home with their kids for
several months.
It's kind of decent where you say,
we have all this wonderful technology,
this wealth.
Why don't we live decently,
not,
not miserably.
If people want to market income beyond
that,
they've got to go work for it.
If of course they are disabled,
if for some reason can't,
then there's added social support,
but it's not cash in people's pockets.
It's decency,
its public services,
it's basic needs met.
I see it as basically living decent
lives in decent societies.
They have a very different spirit to
them.
There aren't a lot of super rich Wall
Street Hedge Fund,
a misanthropes,
and I'll use the term advisedly because
I find a lot of people on Wall Street
don't give a damn about anybody else
except they care about their money and I
find that really weird,
but you don't find that kind of
idea in northern Europe because it's a
really looked down upon a and people
don't like it when people are money
grubbing.
They're kind of shunned.
So the social ethos is different.
I remember once I was running to the
airport in Oslo and I fly business class
and I'm constantly moving around and on
trips relentlessly around the world and
I ran up and where's the business class?
Line a to board and the guy looked at me
like I was crazy and he said,
excuse me,
you were boarding the Scandinavian way,
get back in line.
And I just thought,
okay,
that's pretty cool.
Actually,
you know,
everybody's in line and let's all get on
the plane.
It's a social spirit.
It's the idea that we'd like.
We'd like wealth by the way.
They're not a,
this is not people tearing their clothes
and living in hair shirts and uh,
and uh,
you know,
not enjoying themselves.
They light their vacations,
they liked their boats in the Stockholm
archipelago.
They like six weeks on their island.
So they,
they live beautifully,
but they don't want gazillions.
They don't,
they don't want to do it at the expense
of others.
They want to do it as a society.
God,
if America could just get a little of
that back rather than a,
a president who believes in killers and
losers sick.
But that's what we got.
And that is what's degrading American
society.
Not just the technical issues,
not just the rising inequality,
but this spirit that you're a winner or
you're a loser.
And if you're a loser,
get out of the way.
That's Ayn rand talking.
It's ugly.
Uh,
and we've had enough of it.